aurais tu ne m'as pas sergent à l'essor
de
[Musique]
dis moi tu es de virginie
madame hartl est-ce que brandon est là
il est sorti je fais juste le suivi de
quelques points sur la dernière
affectation de brandon
est ce que votre fils a déjà mentionné
le nom de daniel murphy
écoutez monsieur quoi que vous vendiez
on en fait quoi je ne suis pas du tout
un recruteur madame partage où il avait
déjà eu une fois vous n'allez pas le
reprendre
c'est couvrir
merci de veiller sur lui pour quoi on va
bien sûr l'autre promets moi que tu
prendra bien soin
ouais évidemment il faut à partir de
maintenant vous devez me promettre de
faire ce que je vous dis bien sûr serge
à me surpasser de merde y'a pas de bien
sûr i qui fait que je dis je prends un
fou tu as une idée de ce qui va nous
être de la division des enquêtes
criminelles ces [ __ ] font tuer
certains des nôtres alors on va tuer
certains des leurs la prochaine fois
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je n'accuse
l'armée de rien du tout je veux juste
savoir où est mon fils
à 1h
je peux compter sur vous pas vrai oui je
veux pas que tout ça fasse partie de
mandat on est seul à souffrir des soeurs
craquons garde wallonne mais moins bon
temps maintenant c'est fait vous pensez
et des dieux en gardant le silence
il est plus que temps j'étais si tu sais
ces habitants ne seront plus
mais si ça devait arriver je voudrais
d'abord d'entendre de ta bouche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous m'aviez dit que vous vouliez
entendre d'abord de ma bouche
alors je t'écoute
[Musique]